Welcome to the Heavy Spoilers show, I'm your
host Deffinition and this is the channel where
we break down all the latest movies, new game
releases, tv shows and comic books.
With IT Chapter 2 Now out for release Digitally
in the U.S. it's time to revisit one of my
old videos to bring it up to date with all
of the Pennywise appearances across the two
films.
It's crazy the amount of times that the character
pops up in the background of scenes and hopefully,
this video will make you go back and rewatch
the films with a new appreciation for just
how much work the creative team put into them.
If you've already seen the first video I made
and want to just skip to It Chapter 2 then
I'll leave that time coded in the description
but there's a couple of additions for the
first movie too if you wanna stick around.
There will be heavy spoilers here so if you
haven't had a chance to watch either films
and don't want anything ruined then I highly
suggest that you turn off now.
With that out the way let's get into our breakdown
of every time that Pennywise was hidden away
in the background of a scene.
Every time Pennywise Was In The Background
Of IT
________________
Ok so the first appearance of Pennywise actually
comes within the first five minutes of the
movie, way before Georgie has his fateful
run in with the killer clown in the sewers.
As Georgie makes his way down to the basement
he passes several impressions of Pennywise
and even almost bumps into the character directly
when making his way down the stairs to the
bottom part of the house.
In addition to this, it looks like Pennywise
may be a painter and decorator on the side
as in his home there are several small images
of Pennywise engrained into the wallpaper.
Just before Georgie goes down the steps into
the basement in a blink and you'll miss it
moment that roughly takes place over two frames,
you may also notice his small shiny eyes watching
the young boy at the top of the stairs as
he descends into the flight of steps.
Whilst he also appears later in the scene,
hiding under the stairs, this is the first
of many examples that show that he's always
one step behind his prey, constantly stalking
them and waiting for the perfect moment to
attack.
Who knows how long he followed Georgie for
during this scene but it's enough to give
you Goosebumps as you realise that once Pennywise
has it's eyes on you it's difficult to get
away.
The Library Scene
________________
Up next is the Library scene with Ben in which
there are several minor appearances by Pennywise
before he makes his final play and tries to
attack the character in the basement of the
building.
I guess the rule is, if there's a killer clown
after you, just don't go downstairs anywhere.
Anyway, the first one comes in the form of
the creepy librarian that slowly watches Ben
as he reads about the history of Derry.
Throughout the scene the mysterious librarian
creepily stares at him, smiling as he digs
deeper into what exactly may be going on in
the town.
It's a really haunting scene and is something
that I didn't even pick up on my first couple
of watches though the more you focus on the
background of the scene, the more that you
realise that Pennywise is slowly making his
play.
I noticed comments last time of people saying
it was just the woman doing her job but she's
also standing in the exact same position that
the Balloon appears in in the next shot that
leads Ben to go down into the Basement which
cements for me that the character is indeed
taking on her form.
it chapter 2 easter eggs explained every time
pennywise was in the background of a scene
things you missed post credits scene trivia
Another blink and you'll miss it moment also
happens in this scene when Ben is flicking
through the book, in a small frame that flies
by so fast you have to screenshot it in order
to see it, you will see the children's Easter
egg hunt that infamously ended in disaster.
In the top corner of the photo when paused
you will notice a blurry vision of Pennywise
that shows he was the cause behind the massacre
and has been in the town at several key points.
As we know from IT, Pennywise is often at
the centre of many famous disasters in Derry
and this confirms that he was indeed behind
the many deaths in the Easter Egg hunt.
5a
Ben Gets Bullied
________________
Soon after this scene, Ben is caught by Henry
Bowers and we see a balloon pop up in the
back window of a car.
During the attack as he calls out for help
which goes completely unnoticed.
This shows that Pennywise has a hold over
the adults in Derry and is psychically controlling
them so that they will appear nonchalant to
any trouble that children in the area get
into.
This is why Beverly's father can't see the
blood in the bathroom and why in one of the
film's many deleted scene's Bill's father
is unable to see that the basement is flooded
after the encounter with Georgie and Pennywise
down there.
It's also why no one really ever leaves Derry
and the fact that most of The Losers do shows
that they are highly driven people which plays
into why they all go on to have successful
careers.
Though the one in the car is rather obvious
it adds a nice amount of subtext to the city
and definitely lets you know that Pennywise
has the ability to reach into pretty much
every aspect of Derry.
Ben's Wound
________________
The next one comes during the scene in which
the Losers Club try and help Ben with his
cuts.
The characters are all leaning up against
a wall with graffiti behind then which seems
innocuous enough until, during the scene,
Pennywise's face appears in the markings watching
them.
The face definitely isn't there earlier in
the scene so it's safe to say that this has
been done with something else other than a
spray can.
It's an awesome little addition that once
again cements just how able Pennywise is with
hunting his prey, he can follow them wherever
he wants to and this makes him infinitely
more terrifying.
A similar appearance happens in Chapter 2
as well with the character reappearing in
the graffiti after not being there the first
time that we pass it.
The Fair
________________
Up next is another rather obvious one but
I thought I'd include it in case you missed
it.
During the scene in which the losers club
all admit that they are afraid of something,
we can see a clown on the stage in the background
staring at the group and when Richie says
that he hates clown, the figure reaches out
menacingly to him with a balloon and from
this point out just stares at him.
Yep, that's Pennywise alright and this scene
is given more weight in IT Chapter Two when
Bill rides past the same location and Pennywise
can still be seen poking out from under the
car.
The TV Show
________________
Beverly has a doll that looks similar to Pennywise
and the character also makes an appearance
in the TV show that seems to be plastered
across every television screen in Derry.
Whilst Pennywise definitely appears at the
end, taunting Henry to kill his own father,
if you go back and watch the movie you will
notice that this show also appears in the
rest of the film throughout the entire town.
Firstly Eddie's mother is sat watching it
when the children go out, later when Beverly
sneaks past her father, he too is watching
it.
This is another way that Pennywise slowly
seeps into the consciousness of the town and
why so many kids end up going to the sewers
to play.
You might also notice that sitting next to
the presenter are the missing children from
Derry who all have severe wounds in their
body that probably indicate the brutal way
that Pennywise killed them.
This show is just another way for Pennywise
to hunt and we know that Pennywise is psychically
pushing it into the townspeoples minds as
we see Beverly sneak past it once and then
when she goes past it again the tv is just
playing static.
Yikes.
It Chapter 2 Hidden Pennywise scenes
Bob Gray Bottle
________________
On the way to the house on Neobolt Street,
before they enter we can see a bottle with
Bob Gray on it that has a callback to Pennywise
who famously used to use the moniker.
Bob Gray is a reference to the serial killer
Albert Fish who too used the pseudonym when
carrying out his killings which involved kidnapping
and cannibalism.
The Doll
________________
The final one for the film comes in the house
on Neobolt Street in which Richie becomes
trapped in a room full of Dolls.
Not only is there a one that resembles the
original IT portrayal by Tim Curry in the
1990s mini-series, there's also one that looks
like Pennywise on the right-hand side.
Both sides of the room show the history of
Pennywise and it showcases that the character
was watching Richie far before he jumped out
of the coffin to attack him.
Ok so that's all of the ones for It Chapter
One now let's move onto It Chapter 2.
It Chapter 2 Hidden Pennywise
________________
The first one we see in It Chapter 2 is during
the introductory logos in which we can see
the deadlights floating around the Warner
Bros and New Line Logo letting us know that
these will be major parts of the film.
This is Pennywise's true form and it's awesome
that we kick start the film with a nod towards
the creatures real appearance.
Another brilliant thing that It Chapter 2
does that the prior film didn't is that it
engrains the symbolism of Pennywise into several
aspects of the town.
The parade is littered with Red Balloons,
and then there is a huge mass of them that
appears under the bridge after he is attacked.
This shot is then mirrored slightly later
on when the girl leaves the bleachers as many
of the members of the crowd wear red hats
and due to their positioning they almost look
like balloons arching down.
A Red Balloon also pops up behind Adrian at
the Carnival before he's attacked and the
actor who plays Chris Unwin who takes part
in the attack, Katie Lunman also played the
part of Betty Ripson in the first film who
was one of Pennywise's victims.
This recasting was done intentionally as in
Derry, those who die horrible deaths at the
hands of Pennywise don't get to go to an afterlife,
instead their doomed spirits remain in the
town, being reincarnated and then going on
to live hateful lives.
Mike mentions that it's like an echo, bouncing
back every 27 years and for those who don't
know, this character was sentenced to prison
after the attack, having his life ended in
some ways round about the same time that Betty
had hers.
Anyway, this not the only recasting either
as Eddie's wife is also played by the same
actress that played his mother in the first
film.
This was put in place to show that Eddie did
literally marry his mother in some ways and
there is a big part in the book that jokes
about how similar his wife and mother are.
Other cameos include Stephen King and the
Director of the film Andy Muschetti who appears
behind Eddie during his return to the Pharmacy.
Beverly's Painting
________________
In Beverly's home we see he run past a large
painting of her and her husband Tom Rogan.
Over Tom's shoulder you can see the almost
shadowy form of Pennywise almost controlling
him.
Pennywise could have corrupted Tom over the
decades and this has lead to him abusing Beverly
similar to how her father did.
It could also be a reference to the source
material and 90s adaptation in which Pennywise
controls Tom and gets him to kidnap Bill's
wife and bring her to his lair as a hostage.
Either way it's a really creepy image that
reminds us that you can't escape Derry no
matter how much you try got get away or forget.
Henry Bowers
________________
When we are introduced to Henry Bowers we
can see in his room images of Pennywise on
the wall, most notably a red balloon which
shows that he never really got it out of his
head.
The Restaurant
________________
I have seen a lot of comments on the last
video of people saying that Pennywise walks
behind the fish tank during the restaurant
scene but sorry everyone, I've watched it
about 5 times and still couldn't see it, honestly
you don't understand how many times I've seen
this film.
The Bleachers
________________
Pennywise next pops up just before he makes
his attack on the young girl.
Similar to his attack on Georgie in the first
film, we can see It just before It makes it's
attack, sitting hiding in the background as
the girl chases the firefly.
Mike's Vision
________________
The next major one we see appears during Mike's
vision of how to carry out the ritual of Chud.
When viewing how IT came to Derry we can see
a form of Pennywise standing behind Mike mimicking
his movements and also in the scene we see
the original form that it used to attack the
Native Americans in the area which was a giant
bird and a huge beast.
One of the forms for a split second looks
like the original Spider-form that is seen
at the end of the 1990 miniseries and in Mike's
room there's actually a poster with Pennywise
on which is promoting the Derry Canal Days.
There's no reason Mike would wanna have up
an image of the thing that scared him the
most throughout his entire life so I have
a sneaking suspicion that Pennywise put it
there himself.
It Chapter 2 Everytime Pennywise Was In The
Background Of A Scene
Beverly's Token
________________
The next one is pretty obvious and was shown
in the teaser trailer for the film.
This is Bob Gray who in the scene we discover
was a victim and alter ego that Pennywise
adopted at the start of the prior century
in Derry.
This call back to the bottle from the previous
film is pretty nice and there's also some
hints that Pennywise is in the room just before
Beverly enters it including the door which
says Marsh before it changes to Kersh before
Beverly knocks and Bill Skarsgard's voice
which can be heard answering the door and
asking who's there.
This shows that Pennywise probably made it's
play at the last second and jumped there,
creating the illusion just before Beverly
knocked.
The old woman also pops her head round the
corner several times and does a walk like
when you get out of the shower without a towel.
Richie At The Arcade
When Richie Revisits the arcade we can see
a torn poster behind him that has the words
'It' ripped into it and when the character
goes outside he gets passed a Funeral Program
that not only has his face on it but also
Pennywise's on the back.
It's a blink and you'll miss it moment that
lasts about a frame but it's another amazing
little easter egg.
Ben's Vision
________________
When Ben revists the school we also get a
hint that Pennywise is infact using Beverly's
form as it's shadow appears infront of the
projector before there is seemingly a fake
out and we see that it's just Bev.
In hindsight we know that this was indeed
the character, popping up to unnerve him before
quickly changing its form to try and get Ben
to let his guard down and even when we go
back to the shadow after he sees its Bev it
still looks exactly like Pennywise does.
I guess you should never go to Summer School
or whenever this was that Ben attended whilst
also fighting the creature, making friends
and building an underground bunker...yeah
some of these retcons don't work.
pennywise in the background of scenes
The Fun Fair
________________
Anyway, when Bill chases the boy that now
lives in his old house at the funfair in order
to save him from the snatch of The Killer
Clown, we can see several elements of the
funhouse that feature the 1990s miniseries
Pennywise played by Tim Curry.
They're not your typical punching bag as they
almost knock Bill off his feet when banging
into him showing that Pennywise always packs
a punch.
Also before Bill finally catches up to the
kid Pennywise walks behind him at several
moments and even appears right over his shoulder
at one point.
It's pretty scary and this scene definitely
holds a lot more weight knowing that Pennywise
was stalking him the entire time throughout
the house of mirrors.
Yeah I'm never going in one again.
Beverly In The Bathroom
________________
And finally at the end of The Movie when Beverly
is in the Bathroom, against the wall we can
see a graffiti version of Pennywise pressed
on the wall of the stall.
This isn't in the stall in the first film
when Beverly sits in there and is tormented
by Greta the Bully so it looks like this was
later added by the creature in order to leave
an impression.
This crudely drawn kids version of the character
lets you know that Pennywise will always be
a part of Derry one way or another and is
a nice little squiggle that holds a lot more
weight to it than a simple drawing.
We can also see the words 'Big is what It
Seems' which yeah, re-read it, 'Big is what
IT seems' which of course plays into the ending
of the movie in which they overcome the character
by showing that they are mentally stronger
than it.
This final easter egg is a nod to Maturin,
the giant space turtle that is basically the
opposite of Pennywise that in the book helps
The Loser's Club defeat Pennywise by guiding
the characters psychically.
There's a lot of Turtle references throughout
both movies but that's definitely for another
video.
Your Thoughts
And that's every time that I noticed Pennywise
popping up in the background of a scene in
the film.
Obviously, I'd love to hear your thoughts
on these, did you notice them and have you
spotted any more?
Comment below and let me know!
I just wanna give a huge thank you to everyone
who checked out my breakdown of the first
film and I still can't believe it's on 8 million
views, I massively appreciate all the support
on the channel and yeah...it just means a
lot so thanks.
If you enjoyed this video then please give
it a thumbs up and make sure you check out
our breakdown of all the upcoming Spider-verse
movies that we know which will be linked after
this.
If you wanna come chat to me after the video
then make sure you follow me on twitter @deffinitionYT
or head over to my discord server which will
be linked in the description below.
We drop videos on there early so if you wanna
see stuff before anyone else then that's the
best place to be.
It's free to join and we have an awesome community
so hopefully I see you over there very soon.
We're also giving away a free copy of the
Marvel Phase 3 Part Two Box set on Blu Ray
which contains Black Panther, Infinity War,
Endgame, Captain Marvel and more and all you
have to do to be in with a chance of winning
is like the video, make sure you're subscribed
and leave your thoughts on ________ in the
comments below.
The winners gonna be chosen on the 15th of
December and the set will be shipped out from
then so best of luck to everyone who takes
part.